here at minima park where it counts in
front of the home fans yes he does a
very good job but the biggest thing for
him is to go out there and throw strikes
and throw them early and off lance a
little pumped up here in front of the
home crowd for the first time since
2019. 2018 for lance's case here's a
bare hand attempt by bregman and that is
a great play by alex bregman gets
lorianno who is flying down the line
bregman with a fine defensive play this
is a phenomenal play on alex bregman
lauriano can run but picking it up on
the short hop and throwing immediately
to get laureano that is a beautiful
stride out to the baseball by gary ellen
our matches from super mo and he is out
sean manaya trying to
not duplicate what he did his last start
because that era approaching 10
gave up five runs in the first three
innings
mania kicks and here's the one-two pitch
hit pretty well to center lorianno back
there though he's got room and he makes
the catch so both pitchers with
three up through down first innings no
score after one in houston held on in
first by euler the one two
did he go around on the pitch downstairs
yeah he did says ted barrett at first
and piscotty is wrung up second
strikeout for mccullers two away a
one-two
swing and a miss got him on the breaking
ball there and with colors with
back-to-back strikeouts to in the inning
like five guys batting over 400 right
now
they can break man breaking balls swung
on and missed alvarez k's
one out
mania starts the game retiring four
straight and that'll bring up julie esky
gurion hayes with one hit and one walk
against
lance mccullers
right field in deep and
that baby's gone
lowry gives the a's the lead one to
nothing
go ahead and get excited kaif that's the
second time this year the a's have taken
the lead first
but you know we talk often about how
when you throw a lot of breaking pitches
you have a chance to hang one
look what
happens here on this hanger this is up
in the
well built high to
jed lowry got the foot down got a nice
swing
and we showed the dimensions at minute
maid park
very conducive to that happening
and the a's on the board early
on the ground correa diving stopped in
the shift and carlos makes the play
carlos correa helping out his buddy
lance mccullers with that defensive play
yeah that's family helping out family
right there
the colors in
korea have a tight relationship
podcast partner picking them up
great play two and two to piscotti
and here's the pitch basketball grounded
sharply to the backhand side of correa
throws low to second throws it away it
goes into right field everybody is safe
chapman is the third base and they are
going to hold him up there in the second
base is biscotti on the e6
a chance to maybe get two they get none
on the poor throw by correa off the
backhand and the a's are in business for
more to advance their one nothing lead
time through the lineup he's allowed
three walks in a home run
that ball sharply hit eule is there the
play made to home maldonado gets the
force there no chance for a double play
they get the out at home plate on the
force out on chapman everybody else
remains on base the base is loaded down
with two outs
it's two balls and two strikes and the
fans now
are on their feet
been a long time since we've seen this
trying to coax
lance mccullers jr
here's the pitch
swing in a messy gotti
strands the bases loaded
on his fifth strike out of the bowl game
three homers nine rbis for tucker
manaya
the leg kick the pitch is grounded to
the right side of the infield
andrews has it he'll throw to first for
the out but the run scores an rbi for
tucker and it's one to one
three two one out he is swinging a miss
maldonado's throw plenty of time correa
puts the tag on strike him out throw him
out and lance is fired up he's trying to
get the crowd into this one it's a 1-1
game halfway home
then martine maldonado breaks out the
magetti to finish off the strike him out
throw him out double play lance is
pumped
martine maldonado leading it off he
ropes one to left coming in reaching
down canna and he made the catch
with the shoe tops nice play good jump
well if you break back at all you're not
going to get to it marcanna
centerfield right field left field d-h
the astros instead of 8-9-1 up in the
order in the bottom of the seventh
hoping it's still tied there's a ground
ball to the right side flag by guriel he
gets up underhand to abreu on first base
on another
sparkling play by guriel
sliding on his right knee as he
backhanded that
and then spun around and got off a
perfect toss to a bray you covering
first awful right-hander that's a such a
difficult play for a first baseman abreu
into the wind-up here's the pitch and
it's driven to right field backing up
his tucker still going on the warning
track and he makes the catch
as the astros
are throwing some leather here
fta's have something going and
matt olson is due
only handles left-handed pitchers quite
well infielders on the right side with
olson hitting
and that one is hit deep to right field
and that baby is gone
well have we been waiting for that
he figured it's just a matter of time
and you're right kaipi spit on the one
slider down and taylor came back
trying to do it again and only was all
over second deck
very deep in the second deck the a's
first home run for matt olsen the first
three run home run of the season
and there watch maldonado
watch madonna
he knew it and so did everybody else
that ball just hung there
and maldonado what a great great shot
great swing by matt olsen
to give the a's a three-run lead with a
three-run home run his first of the
season and that was no cheaper that's
the jordan alvarez time for the home run
some guys have an opportunity to bring
in the runner from second so see if
canada can do it so three and two is the
count to canada here it is to marx swung
on and a high drive left center field
way back headed for the wall and that's
gonna be gone
above the 25 foot high wall in left
center field for canna and that's a two
run blast and the a's break it open and
they have a six to one lead
and these have broken out with a long
ball tonight and in fact they've doubled
their total for the year tucker at third
straw at first
that one is lying toward l'oreal and i
think he caught it he did yeah
tucker
scores may have been a knuckle ball
headed out to ramon laureano he
staggered a little bit
you don't perform but that's not the
case here
loriano coming in
and this time he makes the catch easily
and that's the ball game